[Music]  I'm delivering a surprise performance  during the the moment happened after the  Academy paid tribute to memorable songs  and movies throughout the years  [Music]  you yourself was of course hit off the  soundtrack of Eminem's movie 8 mile it  won in the Oscar for Best Original Song  in 2003 though he failed to show up the  Oscar goes to Eminem on Sunday Eminem  acknowledged that on Twitter tweeting  out the Barbra Streisand clip and  writing quote look if you had another  shot another opportunity thanks for  having me the Academy sorry it took me  18 years to get here yeah the tweet is  inspired from the opening of the side  sundae's crowd went nuts for marshall  mathers  people like gal gadot and kelly marie  tran were rockin out Eminem is there I  know my favorite what did you think  yeah well it's so great he's finally  made an appearance  finally I'm waiting and waiting and at  the end  Eminem got an insane standing ovation  from everyone including Billy Eilish